sono un ricercatore e in studio le
piante e tutto quello che le piante
fanno per noi e per il nostro pianeta la
nostra vita
se ci pensate dipende totalmente dalle
piante e chi di noi infatti non associa
le piante alla vita stessa
le piante da sempre ci regalano cibo
materie prime di ogni tipo habitat per i
nostri animali paesaggi spettacolari poi
piante fanno anche altro e sono
importanti in altri settori come quella
della medicina la medicina nasce dalle
piante e poi le piante sono molto
importanti anche in campo ingegneristico
perché trattengono i versanti che qui su
e albi sono motori bili ma le piante
fanno qualcos'altro per noi di molto
molto importante
e a volte noi non ce ne accorgiamo
nemmeno forse perché le piante
lo fanno in modo silenzioso le piante
mitigano i cambiamenti climatici
la temperatura della superficie
terrestre
nell'ultimo secolo si è alzata di un
grado centigrado circa e continuerà ad
aumentare nei prossimi anni
i modelli indicano scenari veramente
preoccupanti perché se queste previsioni
sono corrette gli aumenti di temperatura
in certe aree del pianeta causeranno
cambiamenti drammatici con forti
ripercussioni sia a livello locale che a
livello globale possiamo aspettarci
carestie
guerre e migrazioni molto intense
vedete che in alcune parti del pianeta
la temperatura si alzerà fino a 3 gradi
centigradi
ma di chi è la colpa di questo
innalzamento della temperatura alcuni
ricercatori e modellisti della nasa
hanno cercato di capire quali sono i
fattori che potrebbero spiegare questo
aumento delle temperature dal 1880 ai
giorni nostri hanno guardato ad alcuni
fattori naturali come ad esempio i
cambiamenti dell'orbita terrestre oppure
ad altri fattori come ad esempio la
temperatura del sole o altri fattori
naturali ancora come le emissioni dei
vulcani ma nessuno di questi fattori
sembra essere molto importante
nemmeno se li mettiamo tutti assieme ad
una i ricercatori hanno cercato di
investigare dei fattori umani come ad
esempio cambiamenti di uso del suolo le
deforestazioni anche qui non sembra
qualcosa di importante anche l'emissione
di ozono non sono importanti e se invece
guardiamo alle emissioni inquinanti di
aerosol la temperatura secondo il
modello dovrebbe addirittura scegliere
ma guardate i gas serra sono loro i
responsabili dell'aumento di temperatura
e se guardiamo tutti i fattori umani
messi assieme
vedete come il modello spiega
perfettamente gli aumenti di temperatura
ed infatti basandosi su dati come questo
il 97 per cento dei ricercatori a
livello mondiale pensa che i cambiamenti
climatici
esistono siano reali e siano legati alle
nostre emissioni di gas serra ed in
particolare di un gas serra
l'anidride carbonica ranga minini è un
nostro collega ricercatore degli stati
uniti è stato qui a trento al musée tre
anni fa a parlare di scienza e
cambiamenti climatici ha esortato noi
ricercatori in prima persona a fare
qualcosa a parlare con la gente a
cercare di sensibilizzare i portatori di
interesse o i politici che dovrebbero
prendere le decisioni per abbattere le
emissioni dipenderebbe carbonica
cercando strategie di produzione di cibo
e di energia sempre più sostenibili
ma ci rendiamo conto di cosa
significhino un aumento di temperatura
di 3 gradi centigradi
a proposito c'è qualche sciatore qua
qualcuno a cui piace sciare
ecco ne vedo molti
con brutte notizie per voi
non so come dirmelo cioè ci sono degli
studi austriaci che dicono che il 60 per
cento delle piste da sci nei prossimi
anni
sparirà semplicemente perché non si sarà
la neve e a parte gli scherzi
pensate all'impatto sulle economie del
turismo qui sulle alpi e se andiamo un
po più lontano di queste alpi scendiamo
nella bassa pianura padana ai modelli
dicono che il mare si alzerà di due
metri e quindi un'area abitata da un
milione di persone verrà completamente
invasa dal mare
e qui c'è poco da scherzare
e poi i nostri campi l'agricoltura a
causa di questi tre gradi subirà un
colpo molto duro
ci saranno problemi di siccità ma anche
da altri eventi meteorici estremi che
sembrano sempre più frequenti e badate
bene che le assicurazioni stanno già
vedendo adesso i danni dei cambiamenti
climatici perché hanno visto un aumento
delle richieste del risarcimento da
parte degli agricoltori per danni che
quasi sicuramente sono legati
all'aumento di temperatura e dai
cambiamenti climatici ma poi da in
alcune aree del pianeta
la situazione sarà veramente drammatica
per l'agricoltura la gente sarà
costretta a partire ci saranno nuovi
immigranti
c'è qualcuno che ha già coniato un nuovo
termine per questi migranti che saranno
costretti a partire a causa del clima
che cambia e rifugiati climatici ma ora
vorrei raccontarvi qualcosa che forse
non conoscete la vegetazione assieme
agli oceani sequestra il 50 per cento
delle emissioni di anidride carbonica le
trasforma attraverso il processo di
fotosintesi in sostanza organica e poi
le conserva le trattiene nel suolo e nel
legno per decine centinaia di anni e
così la sottrae all'atmosfera questo le
piante lo fanno con le foglie che sono i
loro polmoni e questo è il respiro di
campi prati e boschi questo respiro non
riesce a compensare le nostre missioni
ma lei limits gli impatti sul pianeta
io come ricercatore ho un sogno e tutti
i ricercatori che come me lavorano in
questo campo hanno lo stesso sogno nel
sogno è di determinare le condizioni di
equilibrio tra drizzare la bilancia
equilibrio tra emissioni e sequestro di
carbonio da parte della vegetazione e
per ricercare questo equilibrio
voliamo sulle piante le guardiamo
dall'alto le studiano da droni da aerei
ma anche dai satelliti
cerchiamo di quantificare l'effetto
mitigante della vegetazione nei
confronti degli effetti collaterali
nelle nostre economie la prima cosa che
facciamo come ricercatori è quella di
misurare l'area delle foglie di tutto il
pianeta
e a voi sembrerà strano ma questa cosa è
relativamente facile da fare quello che
è veramente difficile e studiare la
fotosintesi di tutte queste foglie a
livello globale questa sì è una cosa
difficile da fare ma anche in questo
caso le piante ci danno un aiutino
adesso vi spiego quale le piante sono
fluorescenti cioè quando rallentano il
processo della fotosintesi e mettono una
debole luce rossa fluorescente la
clorofilla che sta nelle foglie si
comporta un po come le luci di stop
posteriori delle nostre automobili si
accende la luce e il messaggio è sto
rallentando e così fanno le foglie in
questo caso il messaggio era attenzione
sta rallentando la fotosintesi e così
con queste luci che si accendono e
spendono noi riusciamo a capire dove la
fotosintesi corre veloce e dove invece
ha rallentato dove si ferma e se
guardate questa foglia la parte a destra
e scura le luci sono spente la
fotosintesi va avanti veloce normalmente
ma nella parte sinistra
le luci sono accese la fotosintesi ha
rallentato questo è successo perché noi
ricercatori che a volte siamo in posa
abc con le piante facciamo questi
esperimenti abbiamo spruzzato la pianta
una sostanza che blocca la fotosintesi e
questa lunga
noi possiamo vederla a livello di
singola foglia a livello di singola
pianta un bosco intero possiamo vederla
da terra vederla in volo dagli aerei
possiamo vederla perfino dallo spazio ed
è per questo motivo che l'agenzia
spaziale europea ha programmato il
lancio di un nuovo satellite che si
chiama florence explorer l'esploratore
della fluorescenza
queste sono le nostre prove di volo per
la prima volta potremo vedere la
fotosintesi proveniente da tutte le
piante di ogni angolo del pianeta e
capire qual è l'effetto mitigante della
vegetazione
speriamo che questa luce si apra gli
occhi sulle reali condizioni di salute
del pianeta e che ci indichi una strada
verso una nuova era di convivenza e
collaborazione tra noi uomini e le
piante per una lunga vita del pianeta
grazie a tutti
la clausola piatta
tutti